Michael
oh my God
I do not want to talk about it
unbelievable that
okay what happened Michael oh wouldn't
you like to know what happened in the
bathroom by myself pervy suffice to say
I finished my business I was just
checking to make sure everything was
fine and my cell phone fell out and on
not in but like on the rim and then it's
not just let me tell the story okay Jim
I knocked her with my knee and then it
fell in and then I leaned over and
looked and my Bluetooth fell out of my
ear and that fell in Bluetooth and then
I got flustered and everything started
falling in my wallet fell in my tip
calculator my candy corn my white strips
all fell in to the toilet and you're
Keys felon I threw the keys in out of
anger this cannot happen again that's
what you said last time I know I did
Phyllis isn't a fun
well technically it is toilet humor
which you claim to enjoy it is not
toilet humor it is toilet tragedy
hey
hey you know what
this is the best thing that ever
happened to me
don't doubt it
ladies and gentlemen a while ago you
witnessed a tragedy that befell me in
the bathroom but As the adage goes out
of great tragedy
is the mother of invention so without
further Ado I would like to present to
you something that I believe will change
the way that we all do business
so to speak behold
the mesh toilet guard
handy portable self-cleaning
this little baby goes where you go
who wants to give it a test bin Phyllis
Stanley
Kev I wanna
who wants to take it on its maiden
voyage anyone
come on
here's an idea how to handle that puppy
and you got yourself a tennis racket
okay
sure no I can I'll double check that for
you
I would like to tell you a little story
let me call you right back okay about a
boy named
it that doesn't even matter could be any
one of you
and like any other 12 year old boy he
wanted a Pippy long stocking doll for
Christmas
but his evil stepfather Jeff said no you
may not have what you want you must have
a football
and the boy cried and he cried and he
cried and he held his breath as long as
he could and he wouldn't eat his dinner
but you know something
it turns out
that Jeff was right because I already
had a GI Joe and a Stretch Armstrong and
a Malibu Barbie and a major Matt Mason
which technically is enough for a tea
party so my point is this I didn't need
what I thought I needed what I needed
was to learn how to appreciate what I
had which in this case was enough dolls
to have tea with exactly got it now
if you will Fast Forward a few years now
press stop have a talk
baggy pants
you are all that 12 year old boy and
this copier
is
working perfectly that's the original
anybody else yep
pirated music on to my work computer who
hasn't good good what else no I'd like
to hear more about that well remember
when Andy had his engagement brunch
several of us got together to come up
with excuses why we couldn't make it
what who else Phyllis I don't want to
say yeah cause no one came
and I threw a deli platter in the pool
I once reported Oscar to the ins
turns out he's clean but I'm glad I did
it
well let's keep this party moving on
I've done some things I'm not proud of
committed some atrocities in Vietnam uh
two years ago
Princess Cruise Lines
Ryan oh but you mean other than
embezzling fraud Jim
fraud fraud sure last year you guys were
riding me really hard for the website
and I just peeled out my Z3 and I
knocked the mirror off somebody's car
I never said a thing wait
what okay
hello Ryan
Merry Christmas
oh
thank you
do you always get presents for your
ex-girlfriends okay we're never
technically
um is there is there a problem I didn't
get you anything because you've treated
me inconsiderably and I'm not gonna
stand for it anymore
um that's that's fair
I'm sorry
Merry Christmas
wait Ryan you're not mean you're
adorable I'm so sorry I got you a
present too but then when I got to work
I didn't see anything on my desk from
you so I threw it away and then
Ascension took the trash that's why I
think it's in the dumpster I'm so sorry
I'm the worst
hey Kelly you know what throw my gift
away too what you paid money for that CD
I'm serious it'll show that we don't
care about material things I don't
understand Kelly I'm so cold
you know I just scream at me are you
having fun in this relationship
sometimes I don't know Kelly sometimes I
look at us and I think don't dump me
while I'm in the dumpster
what is this what happened here
I don't know
oh this does not look good did anyone
see what happened around my desk area
this morning that's why I really think
someone's probably just playing a prank
on you so just go right through it a
prank huh this is official police line
tape okay it's not a prank probably is
damn it people someone must have seen
something
how you people are useless Jesus
Thunder Mifflin this is Pam
hold please
Dwight it's the sheriff he said that
it's really important it's regarding
your desk I'll transfer oh no no don't
can it um
cut through it
wow man he really wants to get in touch
with you maybe it's a murder no there's
no blood maybe poison possibly my God
no no
Sheriff this is Dwight Schrute press the
pound key
what's your 20. I realize that you can
program or download any ring you want so
I'm
a little overwhelmed yeah there's a lot
of choices you got to help me here okay
which one of these is coolest what do
you think
[Music]
how about that one no no
oh that one was good are you kidding me
no that one says I am so lame
you know which one I want
there's one that sounds like a
jackhammer
just really grabs your attention it's
like
you know what I'm talking about do you
mean vibrate
yes
I love the women of this office
Pam
I love you
Michael's got a few tricks for
Valentine's Day he found a place where
you can get 12 plastic roses for ten
dollars and he's got a great line
miso thorny
Phyllis
love you Angela
yes even you
I love
you Kelly
I love you Meredith this is all
platonically of course
and I have one more
and this one goes to
to me
because I'm heading to New York and I
need some good karma yeah but roses
don't give you good karma roses are
symbols of death you know what just okay
there you go smart guy whoa okay problem
solved I love ladies always have
and you know what I think is the most
attractive part of a woman's body
the brains
because I don't think a woman is
beautiful unless she is smart
and also the brains are where ladies get
their best nasty ideas for bedroom stuff